there's a gaming channel now all right
so this video we can blame on Peter I
like the idea of having like a a person
to blame for every single video that I
produce Peter sent me this game uh it's
called depart depart prototype
apparently like the graphics are kind of
realistic and it just looks really cool
and it's very very scary so I thought
that I would take a look at it you know
as like a game engine developer and see
if I can spot any cool things that
they're doing but instead of watching a
video I'm actually going to play through
the game myself and experience it myself
now I realize this is like a bit of a
it's a bit different than the normal
content on this channel so what I'm
going to do for this video is I'm just
going to cut together all the parts
where I actually say something like
technical I guess that might be of
interest to the community that generally
watches my videos but since I am
obviously recording all the gameplay I'm
gonna post the full kind of unedited
gameplay on my personal channel so I
have this yarn chernokov Channel which
is like my personal Channel I basically
don't post there but I'm gonna post this
video there okay cool that's what's
happening if you want to leave leave now
alright so this looks like a unity game
of course very difficult to spot
requires a really experienced game
engine developer to be able to spot that
dlss interesting all right anyway let's
just play it
why is it not opening
did I still why is it taking so long to
open it look it's still opening all
right I suppose I should put my
headphones on and get the full
experience
um all right
settings well that's ironic the this is
like the lower this is is that just
means that high is that tax blurry zero
out of ten all right let's go back oh
okay that's kind of cool so the main
menu is like the game
then you can just hit escape to bring it
up any point all right I mean this looks
really cool already
um this is super interesting they've got
like this
weird kind of noise on like the
what looks like volumetric kind of
lighting here
yeah the footstep sound is cool
yeah I like the sound the sound Design's
nice can I crouch or anything no okay
let's go through this I don't think this
is supposed to be like a photo realistic
game or anything it's just supposed to
be a moody game looks pretty good so far
there's there's a weird camera thing
when you move like it kind of zooms look
how good look at that
it's like the the field of view is
changing when you move
I guess it is
yeah
that's really weird
these walls you can clearly see the kind
of normal map there by the way on the
left if this was in Unreal Engine it
probably would be just nanite and
everything would actually be geometry
and not completely flat as you can see
this wall is like just completely flat
and then the lighting is just
normal map kind of interesting I wonder
if any of this lighting is baked or if
it's all kind of real time I mean
obviously we saw from here or you can
run with shift obviously we saw from
here like the door is obviously Dynamic
here so the shadow is from there are
Dynamic but I'm just wondering like if
all of this AO here is baked or not I
don't I mean I wouldn't expect so just
because it looks
it looks normal in fact it doesn't look
particularly correct
I would say because there's clearly a
light source very bright bright light
source here that's hitting the ceiling
which by the way that's a bit weird so
you can see here that the light is
clearly facing down
um and there's obviously like a what do
you call those light shield things like
a lampshade I guess I don't know what
it's called for for a for this light but
the thing that surround the light is
obviously blocking the light from going
up and yet the ceiling is completely
illuminated
so a few things here they should have
probably used a spotlight that's just
going down uh because that would be way
better and you could just make it a
really wide cone but they've used a
point light which goes as like an
omnidirectional light goes in all
directions and they also haven't uh got
it to cast Shadows obviously so that's a
just a poor choice over here
all right it's getting dark ah is this
is this gonna scare me by the way I
tried to make the lighting in the room a
bit oh I think something just ran past
shoot I don't like because I'm not like
I haven't really played scary games too
much
I'm guessing I have to go pick up a gun
from that other room so I can shoot that
door and I can hear something walking
which is a little bit freaky I guess
should I get a heart rate monitor am I
gonna become one of those YouTubers I
think Peter said this game was scary so
we'll see if Peter is oh here we go I'm
getting a Crosshair appearing here an e
whoa that looks like a different scene
almost like the whole everything changed
okay I'm genuinely interested if this is
gonna scare me or not or a gun like what
even is this it's called a part right
with a double P yeah look like look I
mean looking at this design this is all
really basic like graphically and again
I I don't wanna the thing is I I should
probably clear this up right now sooner
rather than later I'm saying as a
monster's probably sneaking up on me
because the music's getting all weird
but I have nothing against games that
are not photorealistic just to be clear
in fact me personally like I don't think
I really have a desire in my life to
create a photo realistic game like I'm
just not into that it's kind of like
realistic paintings versus like
impressionist paintings like I just
prefer that impression of style a lot
more like it's cool to be able to use
art in like a bit of an abstract way to
tell stories and so I don't really care
if this game is very realistic or not
what I am interested in though is
obviously all the math that's kind of
being calculated here to achieve like
what we're seeing on screen like that to
me is really cool that's why I started
programming so when I'm looking at this
and saying that like oh well that
doesn't look very good in like a
photorealistic sense that doesn't mean
that the art for the game is bad like if
if the game was going for a
photorealistic style then yeah maybe it
missed you know but if the game is just
trying to be a scary game and there are
Styles different like that's totally
fine anyway so yeah I mean look I don't
like the way that the textures are on
this thing
um everything is exceptionally flat by
the way there's very little detail in
everything just as like if I zoom out
and kind of just talk about everything
like everything is just like this is a
cylinder you know that's a this is a
we're in a box literally like you know
this is just a a little thing like well
what I'm talking about is there's no
like detail in any of these meshes it's
all just textures and they could have
been from something like quicksole I
know this is you know Unity not unreal
but still could have been like a texture
Library like qixel is this supposed to
be water
because that is funny that looks like
Mercury it's so silver I like the water
dripping kind of sound one of the things
I like to do as well is I always like to
measure like the graphical Fidelity of a
game that I play like this or like I did
it someone's asking me to review by like
comparing it to Hazel like could I
achieve this exact look in Hazel and I
mean like almost I think the volumetric
effects we don't have anything like that
so you'd have to kind of either come up
with a workaround or actually you know
create those like render passes in the
graphical pipelines yourself but like
the rest of this could easily be made in
Hazel like you'd maybe have to write a
custom Shader for like the color grading
I guess and also like that vignette that
you're seeing around everything but
other than that it's it's definitely
achievable which to me says that it's
not very good in a way at least in a
federalistic sense all right enough
talking let's play this game okay so I'm
gonna okay so that like what looked like
a water pipe there that opens this gate
right
and why is that pixely man
like genuinely why is that pixely is
that like some kind of weird texture
oh whoa
I hit a and this happens
oh that's weird
wow this gun is so okay so first of all
the gun moving as quick as the mouse is
a bit weird you can see the motion blur
motion blur is another thing we don't
have in Hazel
um
it's very uh it's very it's obstructing
my vision way too much as well this gun
and that's very weird
the kind of jittery thing here all right
good so I can Sprint and I can shoot
that give me some aliens to kill
okay the sound designs kicking in I like
it again with your point lights man this
game is not scary because of the fact
that you use the point light instead of
a spotlight here come on
it's making me upset
was that supposed to be a jump scare
all right well you got rid of the point
light so that's good
I'm guessing I don't have a flashlight
okay I don't even know what happened
there
maybe I should help you
of course that doesn't work oh I can
reload I don't know how many bullets I
have I don't know what's going on it's
just running in this direction
chains are they yep they are physically
simulated this is something by the way
I've been asking Peter to do in Hazel
for a while just like set up a bunch of
joints and constraints and stuff so that
we can do this I don't know if he's done
that yet
because he did switch from physx to jolt
into a different physics engine
um instead of doing that which is funny
uh all right good to know that these are
all physically simulated though
that's what I like to say
what does that say
why is it back to front man
it's funny I was like trying to read it
and then it hit me like why would this
be back to front
and I need to make a horror game I need
to make something like this this is
making me want to do it because I have a
tendency to want to do things when I see
them done by other people especially if
it's done
no I wouldn't say poorly I'm being a bit
harsh aren't I sorry
my apologies all right that's not bad
does it was it I saw a reflection here
so that's not bad from that water see
that water looks like there's a bit of a
reflection going on here is that a
screen yeah that is a screen space
reflection all right I was gonna because
you can see when I look down it goes
away
I I thought this would be an actual
reflection probe I'm not 100 sure why
it's not
um but it's this great space reflection
have I been there oh it's weird how it's
kind of out of focus that's really cool
I really like that
that's a really cool Vibe the fact that
this is so out of focus
like I don't know why I wouldn't Focus
I don't know how much you even set that
up I guess it's like kind of like a
post-processing Zone and then you're
just setting like that Max Focus
distance to be a bit lower than in other
places
because this game is using depth of
field a little bit
it's gonna be a jump scare
what is this
there's still images of like things to
pick up oh wow oops what did I pick up
oh there's a light so now I have a light
whoa
hi there
sir
so this time you've used a spotlight
good so you know what they are well I
don't know what to do with you man so
I'm just gonna go away what's my heart
rate I don't have a
smart watch on at the moment
unfortunately I mean my resting heart
rate is pretty high I said it's like 80.
so
don't think
okay
it's kind of nice that when you sprint
oh here we go the music's oh
[Music]
all right that scream was scary I felt
shiver down my spine
but like okay let's be real here I knew
it was coming for two reasons it still
kind of scared me because it was kind of
loud in my headphones but I knew it was
coming for two reasons the music picked
up
and there was a stutter as Unity
presumably had to load the asset so
that's another tip preload some stuff
ahead of time
and just make sure it definitely does
not stutter I mean of course it could be
just you going to another era it doesn't
necessarily mean that every time the
game drops a few frames there's about to
be a jump scare it could just be loading
a new section of of perfectly tame stuff
I like the way that to be honest like
the animation and the weird camera
movement is kind of adding am I here
again uh it's kind of adding to the
scary factor I think of this game
um and the reason why is because
I think I've been here already man I
like I mean I'm enjoying the image oh
I'm in the chain room again kill me um
anyway I was talking about the camera
movement yeah the camera like the camera
being the way it the way it is is really
cool because
um
I feel like it's it's because it almost
feels like it almost feels like you
don't have good control of the camera
like it almost feels like sometimes the
animation takes precedence over what
you've decided to do and that almost
makes you feel like you've lost control
you know and that I think is scary
because if you don't have full control
of your character you know that's scary
am I supposed to go back really
because I can't seem to and the music's
picking up
where did I go that it caused that
scream to happen
oh hello you've changed
do I shoot him
do I talk to him
okay that's good I like that in a horror
game when uh you revisit places like
should I try and shoot him
is this gonna kill me
I don't know if I should shoot him
this was that was the guy was behind the
thing right
all right
oh whoa
I fired the first time and nothing
happened
yeah the music's quite nice
damn I'm sorry I just felt like I had to
do that because there was nothing else I
could do yeah it's I like the idea that
you revisit places and then new things
happen like in a kind of horror game I
guess not that I've made played Betty
but I feel like that's that's nice and
scary when you've been to places and you
you're like oh no that was clear or that
was good trust me
like it'd be cool if I oh because now I
have a light I'm back in the starting
area
there's nothing here okay
how long is it gonna take me to play
this game this isn't really making me
want to make like a horror game
horror games seem to do well like people
seem to like them so maybe I should just
make a horror game and Hazel like a
quick little maybe we'll do that for
next London there or something
we need to make quite a lot of
environment
art though and see there's so many
interesting elements like even this fan
wearing as you kind of get close to it
and just the presence of it like it's
necessary to kind of build up the
atmosphere this will forever be known as
the chain room plus mirrored uh
text room
or maybe the mirror text is important to
the story I'm very bad by the way at
okay this is the oh hello okay here we
go is a jump scare loading damn that
almost crashed I'm gonna should I turn
this down
don't want to blow my ears out again
the surprise
no okay I was expecting something
saving why are you saving for that means
something's about to kill me the water
is kind of nice or physics objects the
water is kind of nice like as in no
sorry the water is not nice it's
literally two maps being scrolled like
that
um but the the sound of the water is
nice
um the graphics yeah the I don't know in
my opinion the graphics need a lot of
work but the uh
the sound design is good and to be to be
fair that's probably more important for
a horror game because if I was playing
this muted for example let me just mute
this for a bit
you guys hearing this like this is not
at all scary is it
like
oh that's cool so it got me to do to do
that and then it said this way but it's
a psych that didn't open all right sound
back on
shoot
so strange that it says shoot on doors
and it's cut out like that
and is this another mirrored thing oh
wow it's the right way round here damn I
am intrigued all right let's shoot that
the gun sound effects a bit lame as well
the other thing is this game is a
prototype right so clearly like
oh hello
[Applause]
oh
oh I got Grace Bounce from that
fun though this horror game it's making
me feel something
I'm like my usual dead inside self
wow okay so that's two Shivers I got one
that first scream and I got the second
one but I just whoa what was that not
this I and I got a shiver there as well
so that's two oh
all right Jonah's feeling stuff a key
yep
it's so weird how it just like even
stops the music during that kind of
section there all right so I've got a
key maybe it's to that gate that didn't
open so annoying how when you sprint the
light goes up but that's good that's a
good move ask to this okay this way what
is this what are these instructions who
wrote them here
are they leading me to some kind of uh I
mean to be to be fair I feel like maybe
there's something behind me because of
the music
whoa okay that gave me a bit of a shiver
a small one a mild shiver shiver count
three
um
what did that open though
I feel like
uh why'd the music stop oh my gosh
holy crap that was really scary
the music just suddenly stopped
I feel like that is the scariest thing
they've done so far like I kind of want
to almost take my headphones off
oh man it's okay nothing in this game
can hurt you Cherno Man sound is this is
just such a good like point though about
I mean I'm always going on about sound
design but like holy crap this would be
nothing without sound design
like look at that
I feel like I almost want to keep
talking just to avoid hearing all the
subtleties in this and what is what have
I done I what did I do there did I open
something like I'm getting Amnesia oh I
think Peter live stream this
I knew that was there because I saw it
earlier but I still shot it yeah this is
it see that's what I was expecting to
open all right man
all right buddy uh why do people make
games like this
that's flipped that's mirrored
no
so that's so far Oh I thought look at
that look at that see how that kind of
looks like a person all right was that
intentional do you think why else would
you stack like a bunch of barrels though
another chain room oh come on
all right man
all right come out so I can get a clear
shot at you
oh is that a big boy
that's a big boy
do I shoot him in the head or chest okay
head oh and the lights
uh that was maybe a five out of ten
shiver oh whoa
gotta reload quickly
damn do I have to start from the start
oh no that's safe location wait was this
it I mean are they gonna now that I know
where they are though I guess it's not a
scary oh my gosh they're here
I'm out of ammo
what do I do if I'm out of ammo I gotta
reload
damn okay so I can't actually run out of
ammo
okay I was not expecting him there
gotta make sure there's no one behind me
on the music and stuff
oh man come on
no I'm dead
oh maybe not
oh oh
I did not like that leopard print look
though that was kind of scary
damn that guy's having a party
hey it fixed itself nice proud of you
Jane the music's stopping again is weird
oh have I been here oh hello this is
getting a bit annoying though it's just
these people coming out that's the only
like content of the game really
is that a glitchy animation
why is the color changing
why is the music like that
whoa
that's it
right right
that's it that really it
play new game no that's it
um well thanks for watching I guess I
don't know what I'm gonna do with this
video I don't know if this should be a
main Channel upload if this should be
like um just a personal journey I don't
really say anything
based on the graphics much did I
that was kind of fun like I think to be
completely honest this is the first time
I've actually played a horror game yeah
no I think that was my first horror game
this thing hope you guys enjoyed this
video I guess if you have something else
you want me to take a look at another
game you want me to play and comment on
yeah just let me know the comments below
see you next time bye